The niece is the founder and director
of the wild dolphin project and spent I
think 32 years now observing
dolphins in the wild. Uh,
she and I have a research project,
a joint between Georgia tech
and the wild dolphin project.
We were trying to really,
uh,
look at two way communication
with wild dolphins.
She's gonna give us a overview today of
her work and towards the end I got to
show you some of the stuff
that y'all can get into,
especially if you have some
background in machine learning.
So thank you very much for
coming to these, shall we?
Okay.
Well it's
great to be here. I'm glad you're all
here and listening. So like fad said, um,
I'm going to share with you a little bit
about our general dolphin work and how
we work in the field and how we analyze
data and then we're going to talk about
our joint projects and see if we can
intrigue any of you into the machine
learning world of dolphin sounds.
So every 20 years, national geographic
covers our work in the field.
And a couple of years ago they did an
another story about thinking like a
dolphin. And our work was highlighted,
uh, very much because that,
and I have been working on trying to
crack the code of Dolphin communication in
a couple different ways.
Now the reason we really think
dolphins have some potential, um,
they're kind of like
primates in the water.
On the upper left you see an example of
encephalization quotient, which is the,
uh,
physical measure of intelligence.
In some ways it's a brain to body ratio
and humans have a queue of about seven
and dolphins are just second to humans,
even above the grade eight s.
So we know we have the physical store,
they have the physical
structure for intelligence. Um,
they use tools in the wild.
They've been known to understand
artificially presented
languages comprehending
both syntax and semantics and they
recognize themselves in mirrors,
which is no small feat lane.
But one of the big questions
still is do they have language,
do any nonhuman animals have language?
And my particular perspective is that
we really haven't looked close enough.
We suspect if,
if you're a biologist you tend to
suspect that animals are doing a lot of
complex communication.
We just haven't cracked the code
because we haven't had the tools.
Now collaboration with sad is
based on two different strategies.
The first is a decoding the dolphins
natural sounds. So like he was mentioning,
we have a a 32 year underwater acoustic
and a behavioral data set where we want
to try to correlate sounds and behaviors
and look at some of the really detailed
categories of their sounds using um,
kind of an anthropological framework. So
knowing their society, the individuals,
because it's a small resident group.
And the second way is to interface with
technology directly creating some kind
of two way interface where
we can exploring perhaps a
mutual language and maybe
learning back and forth
from both these strategies.
So first I'm going to tell you a little
bit about the specific dolphins that we
work with and how we're approaching
the dolphin signals themselves.
A little bit about how
we analyze these signals.
Some of the challenges working underwater
with a dolphin communication and
keeping in mind that we use
computers all the time as biologists.
And it's a really good marriage
and it's really necessary tool.
So dolphins have a lot of
different senses. Of course
they're great acquisitions,
but they also have pretty good vision,
especially a species
that live in Clearwater.
And they have cross modal
abilities between a vision
and sound. They have taste,
they do not have smell, and they
have touch. And in the, in the water,
uh,
tissue and water has about
the same acoustic impedance
so they can actually feel
sound. So this becomes
another way they communicate.
So this is a summary of the history of
Dolphin communication using one of Gary
Larson's slides showing that
primarily we've worked in captivity.
We've tried to look at
acoustics and believe it or not,
we've been looking for English, which
is a little scary, a little antiquated.
So here you have this slide and the
scientists are hearing oblong to spend
you'll and other Spanish phrases and
they have no idea what they're hearing,
but they're writing it down.
So we've progressed,
at least we want to look and see what
the dolphins themselves are doing and how
they might structure a communication,
a system for a complex aquatic society.
So, um, we basically correlate video.
I'm Cindy Rogers and I'm the research
assistant at the broad off and project.
And I'm Michelle, I'm a graduate
student here. So, you know, it's funny,
I was thinking when I was
in graduate school, uh,
one of my teachers told me there were
only a couple people in the world who
could read a spectrogram for human
speech, right? This is how old I am.
And now of course computers do it, but
we use the basic technique with dolphins.
We take our video, we run the audio
track that correlates with the behavior,
some dolphin aggression.
So it's, it's busy place.
There's a lot of sounds. Um,
there's a lot of dolphins speaking sounds
and we don't always know who's making
what sound, which is another issue.
So our project is in The Bahamas.
So here you see this coast to Florida
across the Gulf stream are the shells
sandbanks to The Bahamas and
the dolphins lived there.
It's great underwater visibility,
which is why I chose to work there because
I want it to see what these animals
were doing underwater,
not just looking at the surface,
which is the case in most
parts of the world. Uh,
my nonprofit had a boat
donated Yay can 1992,
which is a great ocean going vessel.
So we lived there for four to five months
year. We do our work there, sleep there,
we cook there,
we analyze data out there and we go
where the dolphins are basically. And uh,
my main tool is underwater video with
a hydrophone underwater microphone of
course simply to correlate Santa behavior
and try to get as much data with that
equipment. Um, our project
is pretty noninvasive.
We don't grab or tag the animals and we
have about 300 individuals track over
the decades and we're on our, actually
now we're on our fourth generation,
so we track that as well.
Now the species is actually a quite
convenient species to work with their
Atlantic spotted dolphins and they don't
have any spots when they're born. Um,
so here you see a mother fully grown at,
she's 35 years old here and we use id,
plastic ID techniques.
We look at Dorsal Fin Nixon notches,
which most people use from surface work.
But because we work underwater
we can also look at body marks,
full body marks because there are spots,
we track their spots which are kind
of like constellations of stars.
So we do this id work every summer
cause they gained spots with age.
And so we know,
we actually know all our dolphins in
most of which were born certain years.
So we can, we kind of take the broad
overview, the anthropological framework.
So we sex are dolphins because again,
we're in the water and if you want a
little take home tidbit to tell your kids
or your significant others, you can
tell them, you now know that to sex.
A female dolphin,
you look at the mammary slits on the
underside cause of course they nurse their
young. Um, we know their reproductive
status, they're pregnant for about a year.
They'll have three to four years
in between having calves. Uh,
we know the females associate with
each other by reproductive status,
so some are pregnant,
they'll hang out with other pregnant
dolphins and the males have lifelong
friendships that they're form
when they're a juveniles.
And their job is to not only try to mate
with females but to protect the group
and try to scout out sharks
and that sort of thing.
So we understand the
society a fair amounts.
We have a lot of metadata around
our acoustic data as well.
And we do know some things
about dolphin sounds.
We know they make whistles specifically
signature whistles, which are,
so these are long distance communication
signals that go three to five miles in
the water for example,
on they make burst pulses,
which are
very funny sounding, sounds very hard
to categorize, but they're very social.
This is probably the most common type
of dolphin sound and the least studied.
Okay.
Then
we had echolocation clicks,
which of course we know a
lot about from a navy work.
Um, and then we have a compressed
echolocation clicks, which we call buzzes.
And these are social sounds,
um, unlike clicks for navigation
and there are these buses are
using courtship and discipline.
So we have some basic correlations
about what sounds they make with kind of
gross behaviors.
But what we'd really like to do is look
at the greater complexity potential. Now,
Dolphin research is always about 20,
25 years behind terrestrial research.
For example,
we've known since I think 1992 that vervet
monkeys use different kinds of alarm
calls to communicate that different
kinds of predators are coming.
So very specific. There's eagle coming
or a leopard coming, so they're,
they're kin can take the
appropriate action. Um,
some fantastic work with prairie dogs
that really shows the complexity of the
kind of information that can be encoded
in a very short alarm call and including
things like a human
with a yellow shirt on,
walking across a field with a gun
or not a gun, et Cetera, et cetera.
So there's a lot of things
these animals are doing.
And you can imagine a scenario where
a dolphin would be pretty handy if you
could communicate whether the hammer heart
had shark was coming towards you or a
tiger shark or great white shark. And my
really determined if you survive or not.
So again, we suspect there's a lot of
information there we don't know about.
So the big question really
with dolphin sounds,
at least our an an all animal
communication for that matter.
Are The signals referential
meaning they refer to something,
they label something like a name or
word for an object or are they graded?
Do the sounds run into each other?
Do they just do they just show things
like increasing intensity of sound?
If I'm going to talk
really loud it really fast,
that would be kind of a graded system
versus a discreet word or referential
signal. So this is one really big
debate in animal communication.
And dolphins have both types of signals.
We know signature whistles, for example,
their names are technically
a referential signal.
They can call each other and they
can broadcast their own name.
But it is at language and this is where
we really fall short in our tools to
look at is there more complexity
in the order structure,
potential grammar of their sounds.
Now,
Dolphin Communication has also a very
complicated for the researcher because
they're really good at what
they do acoustically. Um,
they have a pretty neat system for
creating sound and receiving sound.
And probably the big message
here is they're very directional.
So they send out very high
frequency signals up to, uh,
it looks like 240 kilohertz,
high frequency out this way.
Low frequencies drop off to the
side and they receive the sound, um,
through their lower jaw,
through a fatty Oregon.
They don't have external ears like we do,
same thing.
They receive sound directionally and uh,
to make it more complicated
for the researcher,
if you want to get ahead on signal and
get the full high frequency that dolphins
can internally steer their sound 20
degrees off and you would have no physical
signal that they're doing that.
So it's a little challenging
to get ahead on signal.
So when you're trying to localize a
vocalize her and you see on the right side
of the screen here a four hydrophone
array that helps us triangulate who's
making sounds and this technology actually
we're just starting to incorporate
with some new equipment.
So lots of times we don't even know
making the sound and these big groups.
So very challenging for
the data. Um, again,
collecting ultrasounds has been
pretty recent, at least in our work.
On the lower left,
you see an example of the Spectrogram,
a little the whistle
that you've been hearing.
And the full picture is the
ultrasound above a hundred,
about 110 kilo hertz.
And uh,
hopefully you can see on the far right
there's some harmonics and I'll start
showing up in this,
uh,
high frequency sound spectrogram you
see places where of course the clicks go
broad band, we always knew that we just
didn't have the equipment to record it.
And you see some places
where the narrowband signal
wouldn't even be recognized.
There's no information in the narrow band,
but there's information in the high band.
Now,
historically,
we've used a lot of different techniques
and whistles have been fairly well
studied primarily, and I hate to say it,
but they're easiest to measure, right?
We can measure contours. We're pretty
good at visual pattern recognition.
Here you see examples of four signature
whistles from different dolphins and you
can tell they're quite different.
You can imagine the dolphins
can tell that as well,
and we can measure their basic parameters.
Um, early on we also use neural nets.
Uh, well if we had enough samples to
train the computer to tell us, um,
if two signature whistles
is red and the green,
as you see are really different or
the same if the computer had problems
separating them or not separating them.
And then it would give us a quantitative
index of how different they were. A,
for example, between a mother and a calf
or two juveniles. So these are tools.
We have used a very custom
kind of program tools.
Now these are signature
whistles from a mom and a calf.
Gemini is the mom
in a geo is her son?
No.
And what we discovered when we were
doing our neural network is that some of
these signals are very messy.
They were just sloppy and we couldn't
track the contours of the whistle.
So we had to throw them out of our
data sets for the neural network,
which was not really okay because we
really want it to misery all the whistles
of all the mother, calf
pairs, that sort of thing. Um,
now with some of these new programs,
it'll actually extract these patterns
in a different way and allow us to code
these signals. So neural nets
were great for a while. Um,
they didn't get us very far.
So the process we really go through is
because we have underwater video and we
have sound,
we use a program called observer,
which is a behavioral coding software
for a bio behavioral biologists.
And we basically take a timeline
and we will code our body postures.
For example,
she might see a head to head,
a little peck rubbing another
head to head, a courtship,
little courtship behavior, and
another, uh, reunion or peck peck.
So we'll code that on a timeline.
And then simultaneously we'll take our
sounds and then you saw a little bit of
this in the video and we'll walk through
our vocalizations and we'll code them
in very generic terms. Um, so
here we might see a scream.
I'm here, we have a signature
whistle. Now we have a buzz,
and then we have some other really messy
kinds of sounds and we don't know how
to categorize those.
So one of our main impetus for connecting
with dad's group was to really help us
get at these categories of sound,
specifically burst pulses
to help categorize things
that we human beings aren't
very good at. Apparently. Again,
match this with behavior and then look
for some structure in order to really
take a look at, you know, are
there really any grammatical rules?
Those are structures, anything akin
to language. You're partially, uh,
akin to human phonemes,
for example.
So here are three spectrograms
tour humans and one is a dolphin.
Take a quick guests, which is,
which you guys are experts.
I bet you're all going to get
this right. Um, so anyway, uh,
the top one is,
is not a dolphin.
That's a human speaking
as is the bottom line.
So the middle one are dolphin burst,
pulse sounds,
and you can see they look a little bit
like phonemes. We're not saying they are,
but these are the structures were used
to sort of looking at and analyzing.
Right? Um, I know my computer can
recognize my voice, but again,
he's a language we don't know. You know,
this is one way to start looking at it.
It's not the only way because you still
have to understand the function meaning
of words if they're there. But we
really want to take a look at it. Um,
now that we have some potential
tools. Um, so for example,
one thing that we started
with, with um, uh,
the Georgia tech work was just
asking, is a whistle, just one unit?
That's the way we've always approached
it as dolphin researchers, but in fact,
could that be parts of
whistles that are recombined?
And of course this is critical if
you're looking at language, right?
We recombine phonemes to make different
words in different orders. Um,
so some of these tools are
being applied through Thad.
There's some dynamic time warping.
This been applied with other researchers.
But we're really pretty
excited about these tools.
I'm gonna let fed jump in here.
Talk about,
so this is a tool called horror,
which is something we've made a Georgia
tech. This is a Daniel Close Doors,
Phd dissertation. For those of
you who are into machine learning,
you can go look it up at Georgia
Tech's dissertation database. Um,
in particular we have the
spectrogram up here. Um, we create a,
we have about a 40
features here that were,
that are learned features as
being distinct in the database.
I'm basically looking at convolutions
see what those features are in the,
in the spectrogram from those.
We try to look for
repeating a time series,
these patterns here so you can get,
so you taken raw audio,
uh,
look for the areas that have a
dolphin vocalization in them,
try to find these features. And
then from those features, look at,
see how they recurrent
time and get a motif.
They look to see where all those motifs
are in time and make sure they look, uh,
on the, uh, on the system from that.
We then,
you know,
take this code book and try to explain
as much of the audio as we can.
So you're just trying to basically we
do such thing to a series of strings.
Um,
that data reduction really helps us move
much more quickly and trying to find a
repeated patterns. And from that, um,
from these repeating
motifs and labeling them,
we start finding things that it
turns out regular expressions.
So we just look at how
these things reoccur.
And to our surprise,
regular expressions turn out to be one
of those predictive things for behavior
that we know that the niece
has observed in the wild.
So what we did is took her 2012 field
season, took the first half of it,
trained up a system.
So this is unsupervised learning where
we got the motifs and got the regular
expressions and we tried bag him for
find the machine learning people.
Now for a second try bag of words,
bag of grammars and bag
of regular expressions.
It turns out the most predictive thing
for the behaviors were bag of regular
expressions.
Um,
and so what we looked at is took the
second half of her 2012 database. No,
and looked at the behavior she,
she tagged visually.
So she actually saw foraging behavior.
She actually saw aggression,
McCaffrey play. Given
that we then say, okay,
what sort of motifs, what sort
of regular expressions, um,
are affiliated with these
different types of visual behavior?
Can we actually see a correlation with
them acoustically? And the answer is yes.
And the correlation within class is
very high correlation across classes,
very low.
This is excellent news for us because
then now starts telling us that yes,
there is some stuff here
that is discriminative in
the acoustic environment.
Now the question is how can
you do this on a bigger scale?
Doing this sort of stuff takes days
of computer power for a roughly small
dataset.
So, so these are bottlenose dolphins now
very coordinated and synchronizing the
sounds.
And I'll let you disappeared for a second.
Two dyads and nail dolphins,
sea simply competing and you can hear,
hear them supervising their
sounds and see them orient.
What are they saying? So, so,
so what we basically want the computer
to do is to help us automate categorizing
and coding the sounds as the
video section you just saw.
So we're not manually going through it
all the time and build a larger database.
So the system that we showed you before
from Dale causers dissertation is I said
quite power hungry at thanks.
A lot of computations taking living a
lot of the spectrogram at the same time.
And so it's, it's something that, um, uh,
has some problems being paralyzed though
we can do it so they can kind of do a
lot with bigger iron
out there. Um, but, uh,
we're hoping now to make
some things a little faster.
So that's where we were showing you next.
So we'll let you again,
unless you listen to this for a second.
Okay.
You just spotted dolphins. Now
this is aggression, typical spot.
Okay.
And now this is a new tool where we're
actually doing something similar to this
Shizam our algorithm for those who are
familiar with that were looking at the
spectrogram as if it's a computer
vision problem, looking for regions, uh,
areas of interest. And they were starting
to looking at these patterns are time.
Now the problem is it before,
we are looking at sort of the distribution
of these things and how they change.
Now we're looking for something very
simple, which is just, you know, the,
the main majority of
the regions of interest.
Are they increasing in frequency
or decreasing your frequency?
And that's what this is down here.
And it turns out that's sufficient.
Josh Gad an initial, uh,
annotation of what's going on.
So you can see here that it's,
it's labeling the, the red
dots are the, the, the uh,
features. Um, this is
sort of the general, uh,
main feature. We're using the cluster on.
And you see at the top we have j, e, n, e,
d, j, d, a, e, j, e, n, c layer.
Later on you can see the,
the Ejv as a commander,
a combined thing. So the top is
basically the individual, um,
motifs, the ones that are combined
together. Those are the, uh,
starting to be the regular
expressions were saying. And, uh,
this is brand new stuff.
This is just came out this month.
We're trying to get this so that the
niece can sit there and say, okay,
I'm going to load in this
database and in say minutes,
as opposed to days,
get back some results,
initial results and be able to figure
out where to throw more attention to more
computational power on. Um, so, um,
hopefully we're going to continue develop
this and make it a little bit more
sophisticated but allows her to really
tune the parameters a bit and see where
our best bets are for a future work.
Okay.
For example, if you're going
to hear a synchronize squad,
okay,
so these are adult dolphins.
Now you're going to hear juvenile,
you're trying to synchronize your squawks.
This is something they learn over time
and we're hoping for example of these
tools will help us pull out of our data
the specific categories in order of
sounds so we can differentiate and
look at the process for example,
of development of a vocal use in dolphins.
Now the second way we've been interfacing
is a researchers is to look at can we
incorporate some underwater computer
technology real time to try to look at
Dolphin communication?
And we asked the question,
is it possible to directly real time
communicate with another species? Well,
in The Bahamas we actually
have two species of dolphins.
Bottlenose dolphins you see here there
are about three feet larger than the
spots and but they interact
on a regular basis. Um, they,
they forged together.
Sometimes they babysit each other's
young interspecies babysitting. Um,
there's some dominance dynamics
between the males of both species,
but they'll form temporary alliances
when we get another intruder in like a
shark or a unknown bottlenose for example.
So they're are already communicating
with each other to a certain extent.
We've been trying to look at that and
pick apart how much they understand
perhaps of each other's
sounds and or behavior.
But if we look at the rest of nature,
um,
other species are actually
decoding each other already.
We just aren't in that circle.
So we have sent in a warning calls that
are used between species with birds and
monkeys. Now with Cetaceans,
with whales and dolphins,
we have a couple interesting examples
where they're not just listening and
taking advantage of knowing an
alarm call from another species.
When they get together with each other,
they actually create a short
and send a mutual language,
but they use mutual signals.
So it appears to be easier at least for
whale and dolphin species to agree on
some sounds they use when they're together
versus their own communication system,
which is pretty interesting.
I always thought maybe the way
to go is to just decode them.
But if you're trying to
communicate with another species,
maybe you have to spend the time and maybe
it's not culturally possible to learn
the intricacies of, you know, a
nonhuman animal communication system.
So that's kind of approach we're taking.
And uh,
what started happening in The Bahamas,
we work noninvasively and we try
to do behavioral observations,
but the dolphins are often interacted
with us cause we're right in the water
with them. We're close, we know them.
And they started doing things
like mimicking our postures,
goofy things like a gosh. One time
we had, I'll never forget this,
a swimmer who was trying to
do a dolphin kick, you know,
the dolphin kick in the water and then
the dolphin was behind the swimmer going
just spazzing out because he
was not a good dolphin kicker.
So they have some funny sense of mimicry
cause that's what they do with each
other all the time. And they sometimes
they would what I would call,
tried to acoustically mimic us
too. And we kept thinking, God,
maybe we should really create a tool.
I mean it's a pretty unique situation
in the world. These dolphins have time,
they're safe, they're pretty friendly
and they seem interested in humans.
Now we have plenty of other examples,
scientifically of interfaces that have
been created. What there's other species,
one of the best known of course as the
work with Kanzi by sue savage, Rumba, uh,
who over many decades and many different
types of work designed a keyboard.
So Kanzi could interface and they could
go out in the woods and talk about
things and share ideas and thoughts.
Uh, probably the most technical,
technically advanced a dolphin human
interface actually happened at the Epcot
Center in Orlando, Florida. It
was actually an underwater, um,
a keyboard that was created. So Delvin's
and humans could both use it. Um,
you basically either stuck your hand
if you were human or you're a beak.
If you were a dolphin into a hole,
which broken infrared beam,
which triggered a word in
English or a whistle and Dolphin.
And then the dolphin could go and say,
let's go to the reef and get a fish,
or the human could do that.
Um, but it turns out we humans,
we're really slow in the water.
So the dolphins would make a command for
the humans and go over and they'd wait
and they'd wait for the
humans to get there.
So part of the problem is they're so
fast acoustically and physically in the
water, of course. Um, so they had pretty
good results, no big breakthroughs.
But it was really the first example.
And there've been historically other
people that have developed keyboards for
dolphins. But this is the true, really
the first true underwater keyboard.
So we kind of worked with them for a
while on our ideas and our original vision
was while we're out there in
the boat, let's, you know,
we have computers on the boat,
let's put a keyboard under the water,
we'll have the diver work
with the dolphins, explore
the keyboard together. Um,
well we found out pretty quickly that
the dolphins have a lot better things to
do in the wild and sit at the boat and
press the keyboard. Right? Fish goes by,
they're out of there. So we, we
quickly created a portable keyboard.
We get pushed through the water because
we're often swimming hard to keep up
with them to see what they're doing.
Um,
and it was a visual keyboard with a
little acoustic sound that was correlated
with specific signal, the ship place.
So this is the whistle for scarf.
Okay.
Um,
so the idea was we labeled for simple
objects with whistles that they could
mimic, but that were outside
of their normal repertoire.
Because we didn't want to say something
inappropriate because we didn't know
their language.
Like your mother
does something with Blowfish, I dunno,
puffer fish. They do. Actually they,
you know, they get high chewing and
puffer fish. Did you know that? They do.
Yeah. There were some great footage on
the Internet not too long ago that yeah,
they pass around the puffer fish and
they have the, you know, the food,
the drug from the liver of the puffer
fish. So, and in every animal has
just enough to get high
thinks you'd never tell me I SRE,
I just thought of it. It's trying to make
a joke, but, so anyway, sorry about that.
So we labeled um, these
four objects, scarf, rope,
things that we as humans bring in the
water they like to play with and drag
around Sargassum which is a seaweed they
play around with. And then a bow ride,
which is really high motivation
cause it like about rides.
So we had the system was pretty archaic.
This was in the late nineties. Um,
and they were interested but they couldn't
really trigger the system with their
sound and, and, um, we couldn't do
any real time, sound recognition.
So it was really not good enough.
So we said, oh, let's just wait.
We'll find some computer
geniuses to help us out.
Fat actually came to my lab originally
to try to decode the dolphin natural
sounds using some of his tools and yeah.
Then I made the mistake of saying,
oh,
we can make your keyboard for you
only take a semester five years later.
Uh, we actually have a system
that we field. We're doing
this every summer now. Uh,
I, most modern one is a stereo. How tried
to kill her hurts a sampling system.
Uh, she can actually,
we can produce, um, uh,
these whistles in the water.
We can also listen for them as well.
We're finding the stage where we have
gps and this thing that we can do a
convolutional, uh, filters and start
picking up stuff at any frequency. The,
they do it at a, one of the biggest
problems with this box actually is,
is believe or not the speaker,
it turns out it's very hard to get
enough power in the water to actually
communicate. Um, whenever you see
the navy do this, they have a,
a hydrophone in the water with a big
amplifier hooked up to a big generator.
Right?
And they're pushing toward Watson.
We can't exactly put 200 watts
into a chest mounted box. Um,
so we've been making our
own custom speakers. Yes, I
am a speaker manufacturer.
You don't want my speakers though,
cause they really do not
have very good response,
but they're very good at certain, you
know, narrow bands and we can actually,
you know, send out these things. I,
while while the dolphins can
communicate it three miles, uh, we're,
we're sheet working on our signals
to be, to work at 60 feet. Um,
so now we're actually successful.
We can actually get these things in the
water with enough computational power,
uh, enough, uh, sound
power to actually do these,
do a two way communication work and I'll
let knees to tell you what we're trying
to do with it.
Yeah.
So the system basically as you see it,
you know the box with a
computer to hydrophones to
receive the sound speakers to
play the sound. And then the operator
has a key pad with the preprogrammed,
it sounds in it here you see pictures
of us getting our boxes on and go in the
water.
Um,
we actually practice in the water with
the boxes without the dolphins because we
want to be ready for how they try to
mess us up when we're trying to do things
with them. Um, and, and the whole,
the whole system here is designed on
modeling the communication system because
the only thing that has worked
with other species primates,
I mean pepper Pepperberg work with birds
is the idea that you want to show the a
species how do use the system.
It's like your kids are exposed to human
communication as they're growing up,
right? They see you going
to the refrigerator for
milk, you talk about milk,
you offered the mill.
It's the same idea is that you don't want
to throw the species in there and go,
okay, perform, do what
we want you to do. So if,
if my colleague Adam wants to get
the scarf from me in the water,
he has to use his keyboard.
He has to ask for scarf,
has to come over and get it and then we
exchange it. So, so we practice that. Um,
we usually put a third
person in to be a dolphin.
And try to mess us up and ask for things
we don't have and that sort of thing.
And so we learn how to
respond appropriately. Um,
and then when the dolphins come around,
we have small timeframes.
I call them windows of opportunity where
they aren't doing their normal behavior,
they're there to play,
they're ready to engage.
And we just try to tap into those moments.
And we can be in the water,
I don't know,
an hour,
two hours sometimes with them where
we're exchanging these toys and playing
sounds and,
and having them see the system.
So the idea is diaper a and dive ruby
have a box on it with the computer diver a
can play the scarf whistle so that diver
B is going to hear it as a word. Where,
where are these um, uh,
bumped conducting earphones.
So diver be would hear it as a scarf.
The Dolphin would hear it as a whistle
or diaper. Be Good, play a sound,
a sargassum whistle. Same thing.
Diver a hears it as an English word,
so they're sure what went out.
The Dolphin would hear it as a different,
a whistle.
And then the hope is that the dolphins
will mimic the whistle and then dive or a,
and diver B would be notified in
the earphone that, Ooh, you know,
that whistle was made sargassum or scarf
and then the appropriate toi would be
given to the dolphin and we'd swim off
into the sunset together playing with
their toys. So it's a
simple system, but you know,
dolphins can mimic sounds really well,
but to get them to understand the function
of a sound is a whole other level.
So it's all about exposure,
repeating the sound to them,
showing them how it's used so that
they start, if they want the toy,
they could ask us for
the toy. Um, for example,
we also in the system, we have our own
signature whistles made. So we have names.
So I have a Denise whistle for example.
Um,
we also have some of the dolphins names
in the computer because we have a very
small subset of dolphins that
work with us on a regular basis.
So we have their signature whistles
in the computer. So if they come up,
we can actually greet
them with their name,
which is what they do with each other,
and then we can engage in this behavior.
So it's a potential tool.
This is actually something
underwater.
Video of the word.
There's two people in the water,
both with boxes.
I've got the yellow scarf. They
can't hear you when the, yeah, sorry.
I've got the yellow scarf.
Just labeled it for the dolphins.
I've just asked for the
star using a whistle. Got,
then it gives me the scar.
Now I'm going to offer to the dolphins,
I'm going to label it as I offer it.
And then we try to get the scarf beck,
which we don't always,
she loses a lot of scarves, but it's
interesting. Just last year, you know,
we try to ask for the scarf back too,
and every once while they'll drop it.
And so we're like,
we're hopeful that there
may be understanding that
I've asked for the scarf,
not sargassum or the rope,
et cetera. Um, so, uh,
this year we're going to
have the new computers.
And now the great thing about this next
summer is we finally have data for what
the dolphins have been trying
to do with us. For example,
they've been trying to mimic
these whistles in ways that
the computer wasn't set
up to recognize.
For example,
they will put little additions to our
whistle on it or they're doing some high
frequency stuff, um, that the
computer's not recognizing,
but now we're going to use that.
Dana, we were sampling it and did you
kill her as at first cause normally where
between, you know, a a seven, 10,
but it turns out that when
we went back and looked, um,
there was some evidence
of mimicry, um, uh,
double the frequency and we just simply
didn't have a computer board fast enough
to deal with it.
And it does not till this year that we
actually have a GPU based system where we
can actually look for the same pattern
no matter what frequency and sad. So, um,
if they, we know that they can reduce
whistles, um, uh, much higher, uh,
than we're looking at before. But now
we should be able to cover the whole,
the whole arrangement,
whistles,
not the whole whole range of burst pulse
for the whole whole ranger whistles and
be able to process that and time
and to know what they're
trying to do is really helpful.
So now we can react more in human time.
So the whole idea of this system is to
empower the dolphins to communicate with
us,
so we're not just giving them orders or
commands and to see how far it will go.
And the hope is that with the decoding
software of their natural sounds,
we can eventually figure
out some motifs or patterns.
We can loop back into the two way system
and see if we can use more of their
signals in the system.
Then our artificially created whistles.
So breaking the communication barrier of
humans and other animals, you know, it's,
it's a pretty interesting concept. We
haven't really tried it on a grand scale.
Can machine learning help?
I'm pretty convinced after working with
dolphins and the sounds for 30 plus
years that you guys are,
our only hope is that we really need these
power tools and we need the expertise
that you've all done in
your various fields for just
recognizing human speech in
many ways.
And I really think that's going to help
us really cracked the code with a lot of
other animals,
not just dolphins,
but the tools will really be
applicable I think across disciplines.
And that's one of the things
that, you know, those of
you who do machine learning,
you know, part of the hardest part of the
problem is just getting good data sets.
We'll, Denise has three,
two years of it. Um,
we're slowly getting it to the stage where
it's cleaned enough that that machine
learning can really, um, uh,
techniques to really be used on it.
I'm really understanding it well
enough that we can, you know,
figure out when this dolphin vocalization
when there's not. And, um, you know,
we really think that these,
uh, these machine learning
techniques really can help.
And we've done a first pass at which is
really showing some promise. However,
when the big problems is simply resources,
right?
We need more smart people to look at
this and look at this Dataset and um,
uh, um, to, uh, take, uh,
um, to try different methods.
So this is the method that we're using.
Those of you who are familiar with, uh,
the, um, machine learning approaches
here, it's sort of a different take on,
on it. And so we're really
wanting to do is get some, get a,
a little team together and
see if we can, uh, get some,
some progress here, um, in
the next couple of years.
Yeah. So we're trying to put
work in groups together. Um,
if you want to help
support our regular work,
please go to our website while Dolphin
project and we have memberships,
we have the chats society,
and there's also some small projects out
there at inner speech for those or you
go to that conference. A
summit specializes on an animal
computer interaction. Um,
this also an animal,
a computer interaction,
a conference that's a now part of ACM,
a that has a yearly meeting.
Uh, and so this now start to get
a small cadre of researchers.
They're not just looking at, um,
uh, marine mammals, but also, uh,
birds and primates and
all sorts of animals.
Seeing if we can come upon some common
tools and common methods to go forward
and see if we really can crack
this code of what the key, the,
these animals are doing with
their communication. Great.
So thank you very much.
And uh, I'll run around with a microphone
and take any questions. Thank you.
Thank you.
That was really interesting.
Do you have any idea what the dolphins
think of you? Are they there for play?
Are they, what are they maybe trying
to communicate? Do you have any idea?
You know, they, it's,
it's a really unique situation because
they have, I won't say an easy life,
but they have a, a well-resourced life.
So they have, you know, they have fish,
they don't have a lot of predators.
There's not a lot of human impact.
So they have time to play with each other.
And apparently humans when
we're there, um, you know,
I don't know.
I don't know what they think of us.
I think they think we're
funny in the water.
I think they think we provide bow rides
and some interesting entertainment.
But you know, I, I,
I really think it intelligence seeks
intelligence and I think they really
recognize and other species of interests
like they do with the bottlenose we're
out there and other species.
Um,
I think they make fun of
me. Well that's for sure. I,
I'm not a very strong swimmer.
And so one day I was out there with a
niece and got some water. My master,
I was doing mass clearing and we're just
floundering around and they all ignored
her and came and just circled
me and just all did you know,
just all stood at the same way
I'm standing in, the water's
going, are you going, are
you dying? Can we watch
suppressant and drag it back to the boat?
We've had to had them in health,
like a struggling swimmer before,
like escort them back to the boat because
they recognize that they definitely
sense of play. Yeah. So we'll
see. I like to know. You're fine.
I want to thank you very
much for the wonderful talk,
a very interesting project.
I have a question for you
and also questions with that.
So you said your research does not require
attaching any physical things to the
dolphin.
So when you acquire the data,
you are always at some close
proximity to the dolphins.
So how do you know that the data
that you have is all they're saying?
Right. And also a
question to that, uh, the,
the approach that you used to,
to cluster all of these, um,
rejects expressions.
Why don't you,
or maybe you have like one idea would
be to just run it on human voice and see
whether it can find out patterns
in what people are saying. Um,
yeah, sure. Thank you. So yeah, so we're
in the water, we're in close proximity.
It's pretty hard to build a dolphin blind,
you know,
and we've tried sticking a camera over a
boat and, you know, but we feel that if,
if they're habituated to us and we're
not grabbing them and poking them,
they basically start behaving and
we try to record their behavior.
Now it's most likely that we're not
recording everything they say. Absolutely.
And,
uh,
we've toyed with doing things like putting
passive acoustic devices down on the
sea floor, which is only 20, 40 feet
deep just to record when we're not there,
of course, but they move around a lot.
So it's, that's a little challenging.
We've thought about
building some kind of drone.
Like I'd love to do an underwater remora
that could attach to them and just go
with them when we can't. And record
sounds. I mean, you could do that.
You can do that kind of stuff now. Right.
Um, that'd be pretty cool. Um, so yeah, I,
I'm sure there's things they're
saying that we haven't heard. And,
and the sound is directional too.
They can actually, uh, uh, select,
uh, one person like, you
know, in this audience and the
other people can't hear it,
so they can be very directional with
their high frequency stuff. So yes,
we're missing stuff. We know
we're missing stuff. Um, uh,
hopefully this two way
work, um, you know, you,
you could hear him in the water too,
right?
Because you get a lower frequency stuff
so you kind of know when they're aiming
at Ya. Um, but uh, yeah,
uh, it's a problem. Um,
we just hoping to get enough data
that, uh, we can deal with that issue.
Now as far as, you know, running
it on humans, human language,
we have for I know sign language actually
and a data set that I made as part of
my master's thesis back
in the mid nineties and a,
it actually finds half those signs
right from the, from the video features.
Um, I've done more recently with a connect
data for sign language does the same
thing. We're doing it on
synthesize synthetic speech. Um,
we're doing it on a MIT's opencourseware
lectures. Uh, the timid Dataset,
a OCR,
um,
lot of things where we know what the
answer is and performs really well. Uh,
we have an exercise database to where
it's just exercise routines and it and it
discovers all six of the exercises and
the I'll make recognizes get nicer person
accuracy. So the algorithms
are, are you know, doing stuff,
doing well on these well
constrained problems.
But this is the aspirational,
where can we actually make it work on
something we don't know the answer to.
It can work well enough.
We can get help Denise get somewhere on
the state of set cause we don't have to
be perfect.
We don't even have to be that good.
We used to have to accelerate what
she's doing. That's are a hard thing.
So if I understood the correlation that
was being done between alphabets and
patterns or features being extracted,
right.
So it sounded like we were trying
to take the English approach,
the English language approach and
equate pieces of sounds to alphabet.
I'm wondering whether there's any room
to take the Chinese language philosophy
and take a character to a whole phrase
or a meaning or a sentence. Right.
And, and, and use that,
especially when it comes to, um,
it could,
could there be portions of the language,
and this is part of the second
question that are actually singing.
Nothing to do with communication,
just plain singing, going,
um, comfort noises, things like that.
Or just singing in rhythmic
dawn's hypnotic tons, right?
Yeah. That's a second question. Oh,
so there's, there's a lot of, um,
hopefully you'll get this, this
algorithm. We get some of that, uh, both,
both issues and there's a
lot of work on Zebra finch,
that sort of thing as far as, you know,
just bird song and, uh, we can get,
when we're doing,
I'm a human speech,
we get things like coughs and sneezes and,
and uh,
just a microphone against
that person's lapel. Um,
and a lot of that stuff is actually useful
because he can get rid of the noise.
You characterize the types of
noise and get rid of it. Right.
And there's anybody to speech recognition.
It tells you that's important. Um,
now as far as you know, how much of
these individual units mean, um, is it,
is it a composition or is it
wholly on their own? Don't know
regarding that whistle question.
So your question about is it Chinese
mandarin where you have the different
inflections of the tunnel?
Right?
So that would be something that the
system could pick up as far as if it was a
combination, you know, the tail end went
up, it went down, etc. Now, decades ago,
people thought about this issue and they
looked at whistle languages in humans,
in the mountainous areas,
for example, Pyrenees.
And I'm just a few other areas in the
world to look at how much content goes
between those mountains when one guy is
whistling to another and coming home.
So some of it ended up being
contextual. Like they, it was Joe over
here and Fred was whistling
and they knew it was mealtime,
so he was probably gonna go
get some bread and you know,
get some food for dinner, whatever.
But, um, that has been speculated on,
but that the part of the trick here is
that whistles are a really small part of
their communication and
these other kinds of sounds,
which are the really
hard ones to categorize.
The burst pulses that are
more like phonemes really,
they are the ones that
we were really lacking an
understanding of their function,
their categories and all that.
So that's part of why we started because
people have really gone through the
whistle stuff a lot.
Historically,
logic helps work on parade dogs.
It's really quite astonishing in 200
milliseconds. Point two seconds, right?
These, uh, uh, pray dogs are our
encoding. What type of Predator is there?
So you can actually, you can actually
watch this yourself. Um, if it's a hawk,
right? And they get along well, I
call everybody goes into the borough.
If it's a snake, they'll sit there and
stand and stand up and look at it. Right?
And so conn has shown that they can
encode in this in this 0.2 seconds,
the shape and size of the object
that's impinging upon their territory.
Right? Uh, so,
so if these prairie dogs can they do
this and this is higher harmonics,
if these prairie dogs can do it right,
what can these dolphins do?
And so one of the things
we've been looking at is, uh,
one of the grand proposal we put together
is trying to take all the stuff that
you painfully put together over 20 years.
All these experiments and
all this data is collected.
Can you actually take a look at his data
where we know what the answer is and
rediscover it using our techniques?
Um, we haven't gone there yet.
That was part of a grant proposals being
being evaluated right now. But, um,
uh, we're hoping to, to not
only just do Denise's work,
but a lot of these other,
uh,
animal vocalizations specialists see if
I can get their databases and see if we
can accelerate stuff for them.
And for the ones we know the answers to
see if we can see if it actually pulls
them out as well.
You mentioned in the dauphine diary that
very occasionally orthodontics spottier
dauphine lots to babysit the cuffs.
You also mentioned it's
not really a great idea.
I don't know that they will give us the,
yeah.
So I don't know if like any incident has
happened and like why do you print it?
Do you,
so shark attacking diocese,
what he's referring to is, um,
we described,
I described in my book how,
cause we know that I've grown
up with a lot of these dolphins,
other grandmothers now,
but I knew them when they were born and
I know their grandkids and all that.
And so occasionally,
occasionally they'll come to the boat
or will be anchored and we'll be in the
water where the,
and the moms will leave their calves
with us and they'll take off. I like got,
that might not be a very smart
thing to do, but they figured, well,
I got to go forward. So take
care of junior for a while.
We're like, yeah, right.
We're going to, what are
we going to do? You know,
if a shark shows up as a walking.
But um, I mean they don't go far.
It's not like if the calf made a noise,
they wouldn't come swimming and running.
You know, but, uh, yeah, it's,
what I find interesting about that
is that it's kind of like they are
incorporating you in their society and
they're smart enough to not put their
calf in danger or at least
I hope so because I wouldn't
be very survival driven.
Um, but it is interesting and
that, that's why, you know,
I think the link is there to really
go further. It's just said, you know,
we have to meet them.
We have to bridge the gap with her
technology I think is the trip.
I'm wondering like, since being observing
golfing's for such a long time, um,
do you observe sound
like young doffing um,
like ball without such a full
pattern of doffing for Kevin Murray?
Then gradually they kind of learned this,
um,
you know,
uh,
the watching young dolphins develop has
actually been one of the biggest things
for our work because when I
first went out there, you know,
I'd see the adults fighting or the adults
meeting. And so you get a sense of, oh,
that's what they do. And that's the
ritual. But when you see the little guys,
they're trying and they're fumbling and
they're learning and they're getting
feedback from their cohort. So yeah,
absolutely. They're learning social rules.
They're learning sound restrictions,
I'm sure when, when to make sound,
when to not like we've had a couple
young calves that were real squeakers,
we'd hear them coming from miles away,
you know,
and we could tell who it was a little
freedom. They'd be like, shut up.
You're shark bait. Stop it.
You know. And sure enough,
two months later she shows up with a big
chunk out of her fluke, someone bitter.
And then it happened again. And
it's like, come on, it's quiet down.
And finally her mom, I guess convinced
her to shut up and not be so vocal.
But yeah,
they absolutely go through the learning
process and they don't always learn
sufficiently and they do die and get in
trouble of course. But yeah, absolutely.
And,
um,
other researchers have taken a dolphin
vocalization databases and apply
information theory to them and looked at,
do little dolphins babble
like little human kids do,
and then gradually refine their sounds.
And it in fact they do.
The information is constrained and given
feedback. And so, yeah, absolutely.
It's a process.
I'm just wondering if you have any sense
of the upper limit of the frequency
dolphins are able to hear it.
And also are there any differences in
the way a dolphin might here relative to
how a human hears and do you capture that?
So dolphins have been tested at least
some species and had audiograms made and
it looks like they're hearing has a
couple of different sensitivity peaks.
So they hear best around
30 to 40 kilohertz and then
they have another bi-modal
peak at about a hundred
120 kilo kilohertz. Now,
researchers haven't measured much higher
than that because it looks like it
drops around 120 but on the
recording side, just recently,
last few years, um, people have recorded
sounds up until about 240 kilohertz.
So for some reason they're making sounds
higher than we think they can hear.
So quite sick question mark. Um, and yeah,
of course their ears are completely
different. They had mammalian ears,
they have certain specializations. Of
course, a lot of high frequency, you know,
inner hair cells and a lot of turns
in the Cochlea and stuff. Um, yeah,
so there are adapted to their
environment. Certainly. Um,
they can produce really loud
sounds like 180 decibels,
220 decibels, which underwaters
like a blasting cap, you know,
it's a lot of energy because
of the medium. Right.
And they do crazy things with her sounds,
which I could get into in some crazy
deal till like they can phase out signals
to block, you know, certain
parts of the bandwidth.
So there's some pretty
complicated stuff going on there,
which are just starting to get at,
we're seeing some crazy stuff at work.
Yeah. We don't understand yet. I was like,
you know, was that intentional or not?
Cause it's really,
really on the stuff they're doing
acoustically is really wacky.